moi je sincèrement je ne crois pas vous
savez la semaine dernière le président
de la république était au parlement
européen pour lancer la présidence
française de l'union européenne
c'est un moment je crois qu'il fallait
effectuer en étant pleinement président
de la république donc je crois que on
lui ferait leurs proches inverse
aujourd'hui il ya beaucoup de pression
qui est médiatique et mise sur une
éventuelle candidature la date de
candidature tout le monde est obsédé par
ça
on dirait il est plus assez président et
c'est donc la vie politique est faite
d'injonction contradictoires c'est lui
qui est le maître des horloges depuis le
début de ce quinquennat et au fond
est-ce qu'il n'est pas en campagne
depuis le début du quinquennat pour
convaincre pour expliquer moi je crois
que c'est comme ça qu'on doit faire la
politique juste une précision cette
injonction contradictoire est ce qu
elles ne sont pas de nature à compliquer
la vie de vos militants par exemple
quand vous diffuser trois cent mille
tracts pour vanter les mérites des mâles
macron dans son dans son aspect
européens comme le week-end dernier et
qui qui tractait ce que c'est les
militants est ce que c'est le la
majorité présidentielle est ce que ces
ensembles citoyen est ce que c'est
chaque formation qui se présente avec sa
propre étiquette non c'est la priorité
présidentielle était la majorité
présidentielle et on le fait c'est le
vocable c'est vous le cas mais que vous
utilisez oui c'est secondaire on reparle
déclaré luc en marche sur les tracts et
tous les partis de la majorité
présidentielle sont rassemblés justement
pour porter ces idées là savez ce que
c'est un problème est-ce que c'est
compliqué pas du tout moi mais c'est
depuis j'ai moi j'assure pourquoi pas
ensemble citoyens mais la major je vais
d'abord je veux je vous réponde sur le
fait que depuis des mois nous assumons
parfaitement d'être en campagne je suis
venu vous le dire à cette antenne on l'a
fait depuis l'été dernier pour
promouvoir le bilan parce qu'il ya
beaucoup de choses à dire on l'a fait
dans une campagne qui avait un peu fait
causer s'appelait cinq ans de plus de
plus pour les français vous a dit mais
vous êtes déjà en train de vous projeter
moi j'assume parfaitement on a envie que
le président de la république soit
candidat on a envie de continuer cette
action pour le pays et les militants
dans marche du modem d'agir d'oraison de
territoire de progrès de toutes ces
formations qui sont rassemblés vers le
présent de la république elles ont la
même envie donc ça n'est un problème que
pour les commentateurs absolument pas
pour les et en tout le monde ils seront
tout le monde un câble sur les joues en
ciel effectivement on a distribué en
quelques jours trois cent mille tracts
88 sièges pour parler week-end hors
d'europe parce que nous n'avons jamais
reculer sur les valeurs européennes
jamais reculer y compris quand tout le
monde critique et l'europe au démarrage
cette crise sanitaire nous avons
continué à croire en l'europe à
transformer l'europe et nous avons des
résultats là dessus vous êtes
[Musique]